they won this round but families of the
more than 200 victims of the explosion
at Beirut Port are far from achieving
the Justice they demand
it's been nearly three years since one
of the largest non-nuclear blasts in
recent history and lebanon's Leadership
has been standing in the way of
accountability
trying to
the judge before by another judge that
is politically Affiliated to people that
are against us and against our cause so
it's a big big deal we all know that if
they they manage to do so the the case
of the court is just you know this is uh
it's gone
so far the authorities haven't been able
to appoint a second judge every judge in
there
must know the repercussions of them
contributing to the Divergence and to
the covering of the justice but
officials have blocked the investigation
for more than a year now they have filed
lawsuits against the lead investigator
Tariq bitar preventing him from
proceeding with his investigation
it has been established that officials
as high up as the president were aware
of the presence of Highly explosive
material at a port warehouse and did
nothing about it an investigation by
human rights organizations concluded
that multiple authorities were at a
minimum criminally negligent many here
say the answer lies in an international
investigation which authorities have
repeatedly rejected the International
Community and the countries that believe
in human rights should act I mean how
long will they wait
can't they see that the the
file here is dormant and it will be
dormant forever if nothing comes from
outside
it's been a long battle for families who
are up against a political and security
establishment in a country with a
culture of impunity Beirut